ja der 54 super bowl das endspiel der
national football league in miami ist zu
ende und es war ein mega spektakel es
war ein mega spektakel erwartet worden
und die beiden mannschaften haben uns
dieses spektakel geliefert die kansas
city chiefs gewinnen zum ersten mal seit
50 jahren wieder den super bowl das
wichtigste spiel american football und
die san francisco vor den eines
verlieren nach einer wirklich guten
leistung am ende das spielt doch noch es
war ein finale mit höhen und tiefen es
war ein finale mit stärken und schwächen
auf beiden seiten die san francisco vor
den eines haben defensiv sehr kompakt
gespielt sehr bissig gespielt und die
kansas city chiefs lange auf diese
wirklich gute defensivleistung keine
antwort gefunden
am ende war es dann aber doch patrick
mathys der quarterback der neue shooting
star der liga der sein team
zum sieg geführt hat und vor den vielen
vielen tausend fans die große jubel
nacht hier in miami gestartet hat